before you go 60 miles north to get one
of those digitally printed 3D homes okay
get your dick sucked in a [__] Robo
taxi but if anyone catches you you go
yeah I'm getting my sucked in a robo
taxi who gives
does it make a big difference there's
someone eating someone else's face three
blocks away my wife is sucking my in a
robo taxi before we leave and live in
flattery town have you heard of that
yeah the two fat [__] started stripe
are starting in town and we can go live
like people they got 54 000 acres and
they could have a park and they just
texted me do you like Joe Biden or do
you like Donald Trump they care about me
you people never taxed you just text to
say that the power is going down because
one of these freaks ate the power lines